Guys, guys, guys! Check it out!
I got the original dart board from Cheers on eBay!
It only cost a hundred thousand dollars!
I'm going to put it up.
Hey, I thought Korvo said no more throwing metal in the house
after you got that butter knife stuck in his eye.
These are famous darts!
Whatever Korvo doesn't know won't hurt him.
Watch this!
Whoops!
Oh my God!
You hit Korvo in the throat, Terry!
Go get the voice-fixing ray.
I'm sorry, big guy.
My bad.
We'll get this fixed in a jiffy.
I told you not to throw metal around here.
We're going to be late to work.
Stop buggering about!
Hey does Korvo sound a little off?
This thing must not be calibrated, let me try again.
No!
No, this is working for me.
Alright, chop chop!
Let's get a move on!
I hate being late.
It makes me feel hot and weird.
You make me feel hot and weird.
What was that?
Nothing!
Coming, sweetie!
Wait, is his voice just going to be like that from now on?
Yeah, but it sounds pretty much the same to me.
Nobody's gonna notice.
Planet Schlorp was a perfect utopia...
...until the asteroid hit.
One hundred adults and their replicas
were issued a pupa and escaped
into the space,
searching for new homes
on uninhabited worlds.
We crashed on Earth,
stranding us on an already overpopulated planet.
That's right.
I've been talking this whole time.
I'm the one holding the pupa.
My name is Korvo.
This is my show.
Bollocks, I just dropped the pupa.
This is ridiculous.
I hate Earth. It's a horrible home.
People are stupid and confusing.
This is what my voice sounds like now.
I don't care if it's jarring. Get over it.
And that voice-changer ray had chronotons in it
so this is what I'm going to sound like in flashbacks, too.
You got a problem with that? Then tough s***.
It's called science.